mercredi 23 février le brouillard est
bien présent et le cirque Zavatta fini
de s'installer sur l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines une
installation dans un contexte tendu avec
la ville de Trappes le maire est en
conflit ouvert avec les gens du cirque
et refusant leur venue une soixantaine
de circassiens avait bloqué la nationale
10 le 17 janvier finalement ils ont eu
gain de cause de la préfecture et en
plus s'installer c'est normal
on aurait plus le droit d'être ici alors
que la loi de notre côté pour le moment
rien interdit au cirque de donner des
représentations avec des animaux non
domestiques cependant en novembre 2021
le gouvernement a voté une loi
interdisant l'acquisition et la
reproduction des animaux sauvages d'ici
2 ans et le transport la détention et
les spectacles d'ici 7 ans les circons
donc jusqu'à 2028 pour s'adapter
donc on doit s'adapter nos véhicules ont
changé on a changé toute l'installation
de des Fauves du côté des les habitants
interrogés les avis sont plutôt
catégoriques pour moi à partir du moment
où le maire de Trappes a décidé que du
coup il y avait pas de cirque à Trappes
parce qu'il y avait des animaux sauvages
donc je pense que s'il a évoqué c'est
qu'il a laissé ses raisons et
d'aller à son encontre bah je trouve pas
ça terrible sauvages je suis assez enfin
je suis contre clairement je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les sièges vont s'adapter
à ça moi je suis plutôt
pas anti cirque mais je sais pas un
milieu qui me qui me fascine qui me
plaisent vraiment
j'ai toujours un peu de peine de voir
des animaux un peu contraints sur la
piste mais le directeur du cirque
l'affirme les animaux ne sont pas
maltraités
les vétérinaires viennent les soigner
viennent s'en occuper les animaux font
partie de notre culture et ils
grandissent avec nous il savait nous
c'est une culture le cirque ça existe
depuis plus de 250 ans maintenant
pourquoi qu'on enlèverait nos cultures
le cirque Zavatta se tiendra sur l'île
de loisirs de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
du 23 février soyez au 13 mars des
spectacles auront lieu tous les jours à
16h et les dimanches à 15h